da sind noch immer in unserer kleinen
kapelle hier und am letzten video kamen
viele kommentare in die richtung luca
mach dir doch mal ein schild
damit kannst du die sachen abwehren die
beispielsweise explosionen oder pfeile
und halo k warum isst du verrottetes
fleisch wenn du doch vegetarisch leben
wolltest
ganz kurz das schild mache ich mir jetzt
dafür gehe ich mal eben hier nach oben
wo ich noch holz habe und so weiter und
so fort
der sinn mit dem vegetarischen ist
einfach beziehen wir mit den verrotteten
fleisch das verrottetes fleisch sony
fleisch isst und was mir wichtig war
dass ich keine tiere töten
wir ernten hier unten erstmal unser
kleines weizenfeld damit wir uns gleich
für den rest der höhlen episode sollten
neuen episode lang werden aber irgendwie
nicht richtig folgen gekommen damit
wieder auf jeden fall ein bisschen was
zu essen am start haben wir haben
richtig vieles zieht also eigentlich
muss ich die fahren hier wirklich in
einer der nächsten folgen weil
unterirdisch machen und dann so ein
bisschen ausbauen da hab ich auch ganz
viele kommentare bekommen
von wegen das muss dann irgendwie
richtig ausgeleuchtet sein
und gereicht weiter geht's ich musste
mich diesmal richtig aus und dann geben
wir richtig runter ich bin ausgerüstet
ihr seht doch schon in meiner linken
hand ich habe mir tatsächlich ein schild
gemacht das kann ich mit recht einfach
so halten wenn explosionen kommen ich
habe eine voller rüstung ich habe ein
bisschen was zu essen
das heißt wir können jetzt auf jeden
fall ein bisschen mehr rasieren ich
werde auch auf jeden fall mein gott es
ist eine fehlerlos und ich krieg schon
wieder ein herzinfarkt wie gehts halt
richtig ab mit zombies ich würde
allerdings sagen wir klären jetzt
erstmal dieser blog ist doch safer
männer männer egal wir sind gut wird und
ich glaube dass wir in dieser folge kein
einziges mal sterben werden sind leider
echt große töne die ich gerade mache ich
erstmal zu stabil exponierung
sehr gut die helfen mir oh mein gott ich
kann noch einer die kripo helfen mir
aber tatsächlich wenn ich das schild
habe jetzt kommt auch noch ein skelett
natürlich so komm wir machen jetzt
einfach mal gucken wie viel schaden ich
kriege kuba gar nichts mitteilen warum
habe ich das denn nicht viel früher
schon mein gott diese schweiz peter
schilliger kampf mädels hier sind drei
skelette ach komm mit hüten wir alle
kommen wir da sind sogar vier skelette
da oben sind auch noch welche alter
jetzt gehts aber ab hier aber die können
mir halt gar nicht wenn ich das wir
vorhalten
dabei ist gar nix alwina ist das
unterschiedliche da gegenseitig ab okay
das okay mein schild hält jetzt auch
nicht alles aus alter fällt mir grad auf
ja vielleicht sollte ich mich nicht
allzu krass auf mein schild verlassen
schießt ruhig weiter ich hab nicht
schild
alles easy du siehst du wie eine
fledermaus getötet jetzt denke ich mir
kommerz es sich mal kurz was alles okay
das hat wehgetan haben jetzt mal ganz
langsam voran
nennt mich einfach minecraft mlg pro
player 4014 wo kommen die denn alle her
ich mache mir jetzt noch mal ganz
schnell einen eimer damit wir mit dem
einfach ganz easy vielleicht und noch
mal ein bisschen lava mitnehmen können
ich weiß nicht wofür wir das brauchen
aber schon einmal aber kann eigentlich
nie schaden von daher befinden uns jetzt
hier das hier habe ich in der letzten
folge schon gebaut habe ich dann aber
nicht mehr ins video reingeschnitten
weil ich mich dann doch nicht getraut
habe die diamanten abzubauen
ich baue jetzt hier erstmal die lava
komplett zu aber das heißt natürlich
nicht so schnell
ich hab halt richtig schiss davor dass
gleichen kripo ankommt und sie diamanten
hier weg springt deswegen gehe ich hier
ganz bedacht vor
einige meinten ich solle mir doch eine
spitzhacke entscheidenden also
verzahnung das ist das was ich meinte oh
mein gott das ist das was ich meinte
dass und kripo ankommt wo uns das ding
in die luft jagt das ist genau das was
ich meinte da kannst du ruhig in die
luft gehen hier kann er sogar soll er in
die luft gehen sehr gut okay weil hier
sind keine ärzte gewesen
wir müssen einfach nur alles so ein
bisschen ausleuchten dass sie halt
nichts mehr passiert aber eigentlich
müssten wir doch jetzt an orte kommen
jakub manche waren wir doch schon
guck mal wie viele erst sich auch noch
sind oh mein gott okay okay du gehst
bitte da da nicht okay er hat nichts von
den ärzten mitgenommen alter schwede
raider und lara war
wir müssen wirklich bedacht vorgehen
meine lieben freunde ich will einfach
nur die diamanten abbauen
allerdings stellt sich das als so
schwierig heraus es kann echt nicht wahr
sein eine kommt eine riesige zombie
herde gerade auf mich zu was ist denn
hier los sei sogar so ein williger
zombie dabei aber es geht bei euch hab
ich hab gesagt mit ansage ich sterbe in
dieser folge nicht aber das ist ja guckt
euch das mal an
wo kommen die denn her da muss doch ein
sportler sein leute da muss doch ein
sportler sein das kann doch nicht sein
dass hier so viele zombies ankommen oder
guckt euch das mal ich habe schon voll
viele getötet da kommen immer noch 15 -
an
da geht es auf jeden fall ordentlich ab
eine spinne die spinne attackiert aber
die das gerät okay die beiden kämpfen
gegen dann hat es doch noch ein ändern
wenn ich lasse die beiden sich lammer
bekämpfen
mal gucken okay das kletterten getötet
so das skelett ist tot
hier vorne ging es auf jeden fall ultra
ab hier geht nichts mehr in die richtung
wir vorne es nur der ändern der widder
blöcke cloud und überall hin setzt der
blöde penner keine ahnung was seine
mission hier wirklich generell ist das
stellt schon wieder eine spinne ich
wollte dich nicht boxen
ja in der bar
ist das so michael beer
gott habe ich das hier zugebaut ist in
sport bild
also ich hab das ja hier augenscheinlich
zugebaut aber warum habe ich das
hinzugebaut wenn hier oben wo kommen die
denn da sind mal wieder als wusste ich
das war die abkürzung wir haben ziemlich
viel jetzt schon erkundet von unserer
höhle allerdings haben wir noch nicht
den diamanten
ich dachte hat die werden weg alter wir
haben noch nicht die diamanten dahinten
geholt die ist auch noch eisen
lapislazuli redstone um ein gott als
erster an jeder stelle kriechen
herzinfarkten ich bin ganz ehrlich da
kommt den gang müssen wir ausleuchten
okay da wo kommt der her sehr gut aber
wo kommen die her
ich habe doch die alles ausgeleuchtet
wie kann es denn sein dass die hier
immer noch so viele mobben
[Musik]
kann mir jemand erklären warum da lava
und am wasser ist der cup wieder
herzinfarkt ihr bei jedem block den ich
aber habe ich hier einen halben
herzinfarkt tja ich krieg die krise ich
bin bei einer stunde meine aufnahmen ich
will einfach nur die diamanten ich habe
jetzt alles zugebaut
was irgendwie geht ich glaube nicht dass
von irgendwo jetzt monster oder kipper
kommen können wir uns dieses erlebnis
hier kaputt machen können
von daher meine lieben freunde der
moment auf den die alle in dieser folge
seit einer stunde und zehn minuten
gewartet haben
ich baue die diamanten ab
alter wann das zwei kranke höhlen folgen
ich bin aber wirklich in dieser folge
ich voll krass sagen ich bin mit ansage
keinmal gestorben und jetzt geht ihr
wieder die party aber alter das kann
doch nicht sein leute bitte bitte
schreib mir die kommentare gilt das noch
in minecraft dass wenn man auch aus
leuchtet das trotzdem monster's ball
können uns weiter und so fort weil es
ist alles komplett hell gewesen in der
höhle kommt er kommt er kommt er alle
miteinander
becker
decker
dk
ich hätte nicht so krass angeben dürfen
mit der tatsache dass ich keiner
gestorben bin ich bin weg ich bin
erzählt einfach bei mir in der bude
perfekt kann ich jetzt aufschlagen
ich kann vom boden aus attackieren für
mich wieso ein pirat so ein bisschen
ja ich war als alter das kann doch nicht
sein oder
4,5 daumen ist ja auch noch einer
aber eigentlich wenn ihm wasser
explodieren passiert auch nicht so da
[Musik]
ich dachte der tasche hielt das ist und
ich will nicht als meine diabate weg
sind
ich glaub ich hab die wichtigsten sachen
die diamanten redstone lapislazuli ganz
viel eisen also das wichtigste ist da
hier ist wieder alles mögliche
zersprengt worden
wir haben in der nächsten folge einiges
zu tun an insel reparatur sachen meine
lieben freunde was sich in den
kommentaren unter der letzten folge
allerdings auch noch gelesen habe war
dass sich doch bitte einen luxus schild
machen soll
von daher lukaku um das geile ist wenn
man hier jetzt draufhaut
doch an der stelle würde ich die heutige
episode minecraft mit luca jetzt auch
beenden meine lieben freunde es ging
wieder alles drüber und runter doch wenn
es euch dennoch gefallen hat dann würde
ich mich selber einen daumen hoch von
euch unter dem video hier freuen
schreibt mir wie immer gern tipps und
tricks und dinge die ich in der nächsten
folge machen soll unten in die
kommentare und abonniert main kanal wenn
ihr das nächste minecraft mit luca video
übermorgen am montag nicht verpassen
[Musik]